[Music]
[Applause]
let's bring in chris collinsworth the
emmy award-winning analyst for sunday
night football also he's the owner of
pro football focus and he has the chris
collinsworth podcast we were just
talking about the bengals and
you know they're not going in oh woe is
me but can they play the play this up a
little bit of it's us against the world
and the super bowl
um
that would assume some some humble
qualities to this football team which i
don't know
i don't know if they have or not you
know it's it's a um
they think
they're the best team in football
they they think that they are never out
of a game despite it being 21-3 on the
road
they think they can go into tennessee
and knock off the number one seed who
had a week's rest
uh and beat pittsburgh twice and beat
kansas city twice and and beat the
baltimore ravens twice and beat the
number one seed and go into los angeles
and basically a home game
for the rams and beat the rams there so
i don't think they have that quality
they just would kind of laugh about if
you said
are you guys really think you have a
chance in this game they go yeah we
probably have a chance you know it's
just who they are
when you look at the tape
if you're going to look at the rams
first what's the one thing that would
make you nervous with this team in the
performance on sunday
nervous for them or
nervous for them vulnerability
vulnerability um
i would think because of some of the
injuries they've had at the safety
position uh jordan fuller and taylor
wrap now rap may be back i don't know
what's going to happen there
but if this group of three receivers
could get down the field
and work some magic down there um i
think that would give the bengals a
little bit of an advantage although i've
got to say nick scott was phenomenal
against
tampa in the game that we did
and eric weddle against the run game
with san francisco was phenomenal coming
down in the box
and making plays but these are three
legitimate threats
um
at wide receiver and i think jamar chase
is already the best receiver the bengals
have ever had and that's saying
something because i watched isaac curtis
he was a teammate of mine
you saw him plenty you know exactly who
i'm talking about chad ocho cinco has
had a phenomenal run in his career but
i've never seen anybody do what jamar
chase has been doing i mean catching
five yard passes and
not even not even getting touched you
know forget about they couldn't tackle
them they couldn't even get it they
couldn't even win one hand touch against
the guy and going 70 yards for huge
plays against kansas city and against
baltimore when they needed it most so
uh there's a there's a lot of a lot of
fun on this on this bengals offense
the
vulnerability for the bengals do we
start with the offensive line
yeah no question that that's it
um
it's
and then probably in particular that the
right guard and right tackle position
uh akima dinoji and jackson carmen at
that guard position they're going to see
a lot of aaron donald
unless they go the opposite way which i
could see happening too that
they love that overload defense they
love putting aaron donald on the
on a three rush side so maybe bond
miller sitting outside of him
uh and greg gaines being at the nose
tackle position inside of him to try and
create that one-on-one match up
and if they flip it to the other side
away from the right guard position
then do you end up with somebody else
being in a position to be the hero of
the game do they start trying to loop
leonard floyd down inside against him or
you know or do they blitz troy reader or
don't you know what exactly is the game
plan but everything everything on this
team gets built around aaron donald so
whatever they can do to create those
one-on-one match-ups for him that's what
they're gonna do compare and contrast
jamar chase and cooper cup
um about as different as they could be i
am from a lot of different standpoints
but
i i think that um i think cooper cup
is severely underrated which is
incredible to say
as the guy who won the triple crown of
receiving
and i would argue that you have to add a
fourth component as well and that's what
he's done blocking i mean so much of
what this team can do comes off of play
action passing and the ability to
protect this offensive line
and to
for him to go dig out
defensive ends and linebackers and and
pop through there somehow and block the
safety
and give the cam acres of the world a
chance to go make explosive plays
i mean he's not that big a guy you know
i mean he but he blocks like he's a 240
pound tight end
he's one of the most impressive guys
that i've seen but jamar chase
is is to me has a chance to be
considered one of the greatest receivers
we've ever seen in the game really
yeah i think he's that good
we're talking to chris collinsworth
he'll be on the call the fifth super
bowl that he's uh called he'll be with
al michaels and michelle tafoya that'll
be nbc and peacock this sunday how
surprised are players when they find out
that you actually played in the nfl
surprise some of them because i
i always said my goal in life
when i was playing
was to walk around the streets one day
and have somebody who didn't know me
walk up and say
you know you look like a football player
never once in my entire life even when
you were wearing your uniform out in the
streets they still no which i would do
but yeah no it's um
i i
i don't even know what the question is
no
that do you have players who don't know
that you played football for sure oh for
sure yeah
and
um
but they don't know that
triatman played to some extent you know
i mean these guys
they're so funny and they're so fun
and they're they're all great
communicators now because they're all
you've got to be on social media right
that's the only way you have a social
life
in the world today is you've got to be
able to put on be your own producer and
create your own content on your own cell
phone and and nobody's going to the
media to break a story anymore you just
go on your cell phone and you say
whatever you want then you get all the
attention for yourself so they're all
very good on camera they all have a bit
of a sense of humor with everything and
and there's this brutal honesty to them
so where if they don't know who you are
they'll just tell you you don't have to
guess it's not like in the old day where
somebody's gonna go like yeah you know
try and work the edges a little bit like
who are you again did you play you know
what you know so just they'll let us ask
you
you're uh one of six players to play on
both of the bengals previous super bowl
teams is that right
i think so yeah i was one of one i know
that i don't know about all the others
but
so you lose the montana on both of those
which one which one hurts more
um you know the funny thing is most
people would say the 88
team because you know it came down in
the last 34 seconds and they had to
drive
90 yards in the final two minutes to
beat us and all that
um
i always thought that the 81 team was
was the one that kind of hurt the most
maybe it was just because it was my
first year or whatever the case but
um that was a really good football team
and kenny anderson played well enough to
win that game and be in the hall of fame
all of us and me in particular made
mistakes in that and that first super
bowl and it's kind of the sting of that
sort of always lives with you so
uh yeah they both aren't believe me it's
at one time i wore an afc championship
ring to a party
and all anybody wanted to do is talk
about the two super bowl losses i know
this is a great idea
whenever you run into joe montana
does this come up at all that you know
he
he cost you two super bowls
he didn't he he won two super bowls i
just happened to be on the back end of
it we were the washington generals for
the uh
for the 49ers and the 80s but joe's such
a good guy i would love to hate him
i just love to hate him and you just
can't he's just such a nice guy i i
remember one time dan we were flying
back from the pro bowl together a little
humble brag there
but we just we just happened to be on
sitting next to each other
and uh you know and of course joe had
kicked our head in and won the super
bowl and all that
and he is literally pounding one drink
after another to try and work up the
nerve for takeoff with this airplane and
i mean he was as white knuckled as any
flyer i've ever been in an airplane with
and just couldn't talk couldn't function
and was just it was making him crazy and
i go are you really joe montana is this
the guy
that beat us every way imaginable when i
was playing for cincinnati um but he's
he's a humble guy and i i can't even
find it in me to hate him do you have
any issues with the pro bowl
i don't watch the pro ball
[Laughter]
we used to we used to announce that is
it still as bad as it was
there's no tackling chris they they
played two-man touch on uh on sunday i i
i i don't watch that i really like
football
and if i want to watch two-hand touch i
might go watch some kids when do you
meet with the coaches in the
quarterbacks
wednesday
and thursday so we'll go out i went to a
bengals practice the other day while i
was in cincinnati
and um but we will go wednesday and
thursday to watch both practices i'll
leave you with this the bengals will win
if
if they can get it protected i mean it's
really about as simple as that that
and you know they're not going to get it
protected
every down these guys are just too good
up front
can they get it protected when they have
chances for big plays and if they can
these receivers can make big plays out
chris thank you as always we appreciate
uh your contributions the entire season
we'll be watching on sunday
all right dan good seeing you that's
chris collinsworth he'll be on the call
with al michaels michelle tafoya i think
that's michelle's final game i think
she's retiring and uh what a classy
classy woman great reporter and uh i
think this is her last game